[Music]
hi I'm Gary Alan's Capaldi hi I'm cam
and ten threats of Netflix's queer right
my name is Nick helm - and I'm Freddie
Flintoff and these are my shocking
answers Scott is my question bodyguard
and I want to skip a question I'll press
the buzzer he'll get a shock you got to
go are you
you like it you like a better younger me
aren't ya some things I put I put my
belly button my finger in my belly
button
I don't give a sniff is about it is a
very good it's a very good gauge of leg
how bad do I smell oh no what is the
most disgusting habit Oh easy it I buy
my mails constantly I got my time no you
cannot buy your - nut cheerios nobody
wants [ __ ] you if you bite your toenails
okay if you switch changes of the day
what is the first thing you do
[Laughter]
okay what was the lowest point of your
career
probably [ __ ] on the pitch okay play
snog marry avoid with the Fab five but I
will tell you is we played this game and
almost broke us really because I refuse
to sleep with Jonathan bernis there is a
video but there is a video simply of
Johnson saying who was the worst player
you've played with worst player play
with you guys
like I don't think of a few I think
it's you it's the most egregious Liberty
in the entire there's like five okay so
I'm gonna list three first one is who
was the worst pundit you've had on much
of the day
oh dear God look at this what is that
last here X have you ever peed in the
shower every day do you know I save it
to gain the show this is normal right
have you peed in the shower in the last
year definite in like the last 35 years
no oh baby shower who does you oh you
definitely have done this have you paid
in the shower and the last year but peed
me show my last photo of have you peed
in the shower in the last year no and I
to go before they sense me finish it I
prefer not to speak what is the image on
your phone that you would at least like
to get public image on the phone Yeah
[Music]
right about now have you ever seen I
received a nude photo I have never sent
and it fall because it's a [ __ ] war
fully unimpressive
a piece of work that I've got going on I
mean no one's gonna look at that and go
that looks appetizing I have definitely
I have received nude photos on occasion
because s 2019 what is your favorite
flavor of Walkers crisps salt vinegar so
you've really got no fan you're not fun
that's all very electric shock at Fernan
all right
about to talk ever okay who is the worst
dress celebrity the trumpet the trumpet
Donald yeah agree who is the worst dress
member of the top gear team say yourself
designer what was the last thing you
googled on your phone it was a
restaurant where I should've go and to
get them to get their dress okay it's
not sorry about the phone
it's the most embarrassing thing you
have ever done besides from this that's
the rules of the game why you position I
got out why are you saying like a [ __ ]
action figure would you rather have a
finger for a penis or penis for a finger
I'd rather my penis be a finger because
I'll tell you why because okay every day
I don't want to look and have one one
finger that looks like a pig but I
always think that even if it was to
paint your finger yeah still do some
acquit yeah but fake finger would you
rather have a finger for penis or penis
for finger what
a finger for penis or penis for a finger
I'm okay
would you date someone shorter than you
oh yeah absolutely yeah yeah no issue is
your husband - oh sure she's an inch
taller but if it's fair if they're Alan
Shearer in right or yourself who was the
better striker on me that's it take a
second out of that Oh Oh God good no
excuse excuse do you stand up course sit
down when you wipe your bum that is a
great question I sort of go sort of
in-between because I like to stand up
because I like to look back at what's
been created
also to double-check you have done a
[ __ ] I might have [ __ ] myself since we
started this I really want it I really
want to explain it like and all people
see that you shouldn't stand up because
it congeals and it's like peeling back
like a okay feel about like I'd like I
tossed the chocolate we Nutella on fire
if anybody's watching right I know again
I know this is may be fun
stop [ __ ] sand down and wiping your
ass and [ __ ] add the shoes go with
Jose and Dawn weight towards your
genitals who is your we did celebrity
crush James Corden oh yes did you just
say you like the chubster yeah sorry he
would have been the worst person today
on the island yeah who is the most
stupid I'm sorry
question the other ones are 295 hearts
of these who is hotter you will
Chrissy's ha ha ha
see you altered it you said Chris is hot
but you still delivered there all right
so opposite saying it you've let me down
which celebrity would you most want to
go on a date with I think I've never
liked to go on a date with someone like
Jon Hamm he's gonna look after you
basically he should be the captain
though sexual he's gonna take care yeah
and after what the thing is just gonna
hold me and my boys just gonna have a
really weird celebrity would you most
want to go on date with Medea's date
with remind for 14 years
do you know what you know what you are
gonna do with Owen car that's what that
be the person you guys he's amazing oh
so funny we get value you have a great
night out though if you had to punch a
famous person you would you puns I do
have an answer if you had to punch a
famous person who would you punch Piers
Morgan tell ya I'd electrocute them as
well yeah what is the least acceptable
belief that you hold oh god that is
actually quite a difficult question
there's so many outdated beliefs that I
have really can't get away with I why
think of an answer in time the
administration of this game is [ __ ]
unacceptable right
what is your sexiest feature what is
your sexiest feature there is a fire
okay where's your sexiest feature - is
it on - yeah it's good what's the worst
gift you've ever received from your
husband last question - so Scott was my
biggest fan this is shocking oh jeez
thank you very much we'll just do one
for the lord by buzz Sullivan are you
[ __ ] watching this it should have been
me that got shots
sorry just so you know this only happens
of the lad Bible shocking answers we
have two sex slaves either I'm gonna let
you behind the curve
but unfortunately the two people at this
stage we're just getting shocked when
these two pricks feel like it because
they cannot see what's happening in the
game so the buzzers up on the table and
they're lying on the floor and whenever
one of us pushes the buzzer one of the
guys that I don't see the buzzer has to
shock us
[Laughter]
you